so obviously big shake-up we wanted to
address that quickly but we don't want
to take too much time because we're here
to have fun and look at some cool stuff
you guys haven't seen yet but yeah about
the the pulling it off the channel and
moving to digital exclusively you know
it's part of this huge sea change really
muted in the whole industry I mean you
guys I'm sure you've seen articles cable
cutters and you know we're seeing
Digital streaming you know companies
doing their own content and winning
Emmys and all sorts of stuff so
obviously we're in the midst of this big
change and things have changed just for
us between when we did avatar between
2005 and 2008 when those aired and then
when we came back on the air and she
doesn't well you know when when book 1
of Korra came out it did it's a pretty
good numbers on TV but its online
presence was just insane not only the
chatter from all those all of the fans
all over the world but the actual
numbers in terms of digital downloads
Digital streaming they've just been he
vision and as this show has gone along
by the time we got to book two the
numbers of the the digital streaming
they greatly outweighed what was
happening on the channel it snows a
secret that labs are especially Cora
aren't typical kind of Nickelodeon fair
and so they've had a kind of a hard time
trying to fit it into their into their
programming but basically the book 2
finale the numbers were insane they were
when they streamed it when when it went
on Nick calm it was the biggest
streaming event they had had the entire
year and that show for digital downloads
with our you know that that season was
was amazing so and then obviously as
you've seen not so much on the channel
so it's just it's just part of this
shift over it definitely caught us by
surprise
it wasn't necessarily done in smoothest
way and and that was said thank you many
of you had thoughts as well so yeah
we're you know we're it's moving over to
digital this is actually it was a plan
that's kind of in place earlier they
changed course and they went back to it
so what kind of happen to know a little
bit of a messy way but thanks for
sticking with us the show is not
canceled
yeah they parted in a big way definitely
want you guys to understand is that it
really has no effect on what the show is
or the stories we're telling because
we've we finished the writing for the
series we've finished all the
pre-production and we're just doing post
and studio viewers finishing the
animation so other than it not being on
the Nickelodeon main channel nothing too
strange isn't good to see it which is
the important thing and you can actually
they're gonna start putting it online
starting next Friday so just first and
then there's gonna be a new episode
every week after that until August 22nd
when they do the two-part season 3
finale three will be out by the engineer
so we're gonna we're going to show you
guys an episode he's not aired
as I don't say it's a doozy I know some
of you it's we don't know how to make a
show where it's entertaining and
exciting but nothing bad ever happens
I'm sure I did it yet so hope you enjoy
this episode yeah and this is this is
written by over there let's go
corner with these are these are some
questions that fans submitted online and
someone named John was wondering for
Janet how would you rate cordis job is
the avatar so far how do you think she's
doing well obviously that this is a
question that I get asked a lot at the
consulate I do and sometimes it's put
really nicely and sometimes it's put
crumbly sometimes we were like do you
like but you know I think this is just
the episode that we got a chance to
watch it's such a great example to me of
you know she's tough some classic horror
moments where she did full savage but
it's such a great example of how much
she's come to understand that she may be
the Avatar but that doesn't mean that
she can do her job alone and it's just
so exciting to see you know the team
together and and so I think you know
she's she's on her journey you know
she's on the arc that might get Bryan
had always envisioned for her and I'm
proud of her and she's infuriating and
wonderful and strong and very human we
have a question about about the voice
acting process and what that's like
and when you guys hit the scripts like
do you have time to read it beforehand
or and are you guys as
socially compromised by these storylines
as the fans seem to be my first start
the show we got the scripts usually we
just get the scripts tonight before we
come in and you know and then we get in
there and though usually sometimes we
have the whole cast together we're all
available which is great we're all in
the same room and we got mics in front
of us and we've got our lines and it's
it's tremendous and it's a lot of fun
and in the first episode of book 3 be
silent or in a song here now like the
end that's right how you seen some of
these like friendship developing and
seeing that Mike started as rivals but
now they're kind of friends and I love
it my parents are actually especially
fond of that scene in the car they had
seen the episode before me and they're
like oh my god I thought you're so cute
like does it take so long sometimes I
forget what happens and I'm surprised by
the storyline 30-knot um but I'm happy I
at any instance where two girls can like
not let a guy get in between them I
think it's a good thing
I think they're maturing there is a guy
right in the middle but ya know I'm
happy for them I think they're stronger
together and they make team avatar
better for it Amaka has to deal with the
awkwardness and we've gotten over that
so that's good the tables a journey
since you came in and book two you know
one my favorites the humor he brings I
mean every time he comes it is amazing
in this array the most what do you think
truly characters well first of all I
want to say how thrilled I am to be a
part of this Universal sudden I'm amazed
with what I've seen today right in front
of me I honestly thought I was going to
be doing a press thing with about 20
people in the room you put many zeroes
well great you know it's not really part
of my gig usually I do it so I get to
fly around and bend cars with my face
and that sort of thing no you're just
sort of a talks too much
all day every junk no I think part of
the fun of Eric particularly seeing how
you have another episode is that he does
sort of bridge the gap between our world
and and the other world in an
interesting way he's sort of part you
know Rupert Murdoch and Thomas Edison
and you know both of the clown doll all
rolled together and I think he's
captivating because he has so little
respect
basically for part poor old magic and
Wonder and power and mightiness that's
going on around him and so it's he
regards as either helpful or not helpful
to him and what he needs to do so it's a
fascinating character and he is
constantly surprising me and I think he
surprises the writers is it's always so
fun to show up in the room and see this
series wearing socks about his childhood
it is beyond belief we got a really
special question here and create your
bride a mirror for asking us you you've
inspired us so he had a question that
said can we have the voice actors sing
secret tunnel as the camera
which I think we can do that but but
before we do that I want you invited a
special guest to the panel you might
know him as a voice of every other on
the universe
we also with this PT play the original
character Chong from virtue of the
avatar all right there get good
insurance to sing John Johnson self sing
along great story about a secret pass
right through the mountains is this real
or a legend
all rights a real legend and it's as old
as earthbending itself
forget the next couple lines
I did for a year you know after books
wanted to thought Tarlac it a lot kind
of look the same so I wanted to do
something very different so I went for
sort of an MMA fighter kind of catch
wrestling guy someone that didn't he
kind of bulky this is reuse concept that
he did after mine of course
complete with reduced crazy color
combinations were you are you here buddy
genius so then I did a constant we know
he's gonna be a prison for a long time
they probably didn't let him groom so
it's gonna grow some hair and Ryu did
these incredible expression sheets of
him when he's busting his buddy out of
the barge and they use his hair metal
talk here what's what he's gonna look
like for residences and so you can see
if you ever think his ears look strange
like maybe they didn't draw him well I
was actually intentionally supposed to
have cauliflower ear from a career
fighting so there is on just my first
concept for him always I don't have any
tattoos but I'm still like dude
character in a and his on and so this
reuse concepts are expression sheets of
his head and then I had to work out the
tattoos it's always tough because it's
hard to do kind of graphic patterns
moving over shapes you know keeping them
consistent but these were fun to do and
then make mob favorite character bars to
conceive of and design and this is based
on she's just basically my friend
meetcha meetcha does have arms a fleshie
but not a water
and then so here he is incredible
expression sheets for her and then so my
the model she just kind of explaining
the different things she could do with
her her malleable arms and and please
another fun one to design this is Angela
Bueller are you here ads on over there
so Angelo is an old friend and great
character designer who works on ABS
otherwise Airbender and when she was
gonna work on core I said hey take a
stab at this this is like firebending
assassin and so she did this crazy kind
of Lisbeth Salander looking character
and I liked it and this is some cool
head she did for that and I said let's
make her six feet so this is my my
version of it based on her design and we
kind of finished it together and we have
our next combustion vendor and so then
when they were busting out fully we had
to like give them winter costumes so we
kind of like winterized everybody and
Christy's saying our other character
designer and Angie were turning in no
different concepts and and she turned in
this one for here she's I got you know
like really done in lon oh I've got some
alternate once too for you to consider
oh we were gonna go
the right recycles yard anime as unsee
that for you did as you know is here is
voiced by legendary Henry Rollins as we
like to call him the most interesting
man in the world this morn many hats but
he's you know he built his career as a
legendary punk singer so were you did
this awesome we're happy metal clan
students family which was really fun
doing this Art Deco city and art deco
fashion and jewelry this was my first
concept for her and what we ended up
with when she was in color and her
husband in guitar you want to see a
little bit so far he's the architect and
guitar jr. I swear that that expression
looks like David Schwimmer to pieces now
you only see a charging you very briefly
in the doorway but he doesn't just so
he's he works in the city and huan
really so I'm doing all he's very fun
and then we've got his final color it
was really fun doing all the different
variations on this kind of like utopia
Art Deco outfits opal was really fun to
design I did a regional concept and then
we've got her color model she's kind of
like a little flapper and then wing away
aka some locks and same on
we've got any mirror image twins you'll
notice their hair carts opposite and
their jewelry on their little will do
that are opposite of each other they're
fine
they really remind me of Josh our writer
like cool girl
a man is so tiny and I wanted to show
you know we're likely gonna be a New
York comic-con if any of you to make it
out there but this is probably the last
big big cork now so you guys are the
best
we seriously love all of you thank you
Mike put together special treat for you
guys so the rolls will enjoy and we will
see some of you